[Music]
for the last most part - we're hoping to
create a story that makes a commentary
about the psycho violence and how acts
can beget other acts and show all the
different aspects that can come out of
it nothing's really good or bad just the
different consequences of one's actions
I'm gonna find and I'm gonna kill I
[Music]
heard a lot of people say why make a
sequel to The Last of Us I didn't even
hear the full pitch of the game but just
like the outline of what Neill was
wanting to do with this game I realized
oh this is something we have to make
this you know this isn't even an option
but there's absolutely more to do here
there's always the fear that you know
when you made something great and you're
gonna go back to it you're gonna mess it
up you're gonna mess what made it so
special the test for us was like can we
come up with a story that can one stand
on its own and be meaningful and have it
wait the same kind of feeling we had
when we came upon the story for the
first one but also now because it's part
two it has to be added it has to take
the first one to consideration that if
you played both then you get like a
bigger narrative the thing that Neill
really cared about that the studio
really cared about is honoring Ellie and
Joel specifically and their journey as
characters what is the honest next steps
that they would take what are the truest
moves that we could see them do the last
was - expands on the first game both in
the relationship between Ellie and Joel
the relationships that we see Ellie
having and just the greater worlds that
were in and we see more of it
it's a genre story about this infection
that turns people into these crazy
monster like humanoids the core of it is
about these really intimate intense
relationships at the start of the game
Ellie is 19 she is living in a safe
secure community we're coming in you
know 25 years after the outbreak and you
as Ellie live in Jackson which is this
kind of somewhat tranquil town in this
really messed up reality she has real
community now she has people who love
and care for her willing to sacrifice
for her Joel is also very settled down
he's now part of a town he's no longer a
smuggler actually the town relies on
this guy that is a very capable killer
and that's something these towns and
this world needs
and then Jackson and Ellie are shaken by
a violent event it really changes
Ellie's day to day life and now just
living is no longer enough like there's
these people that I've wronged her and
she wants retribution and you as a
player gonna want retribution for what
these people of them and then you go off
on this journey that leads you to
Seattle where now you're like stuck in
the city that has these warring factions
and they're both fighting over the
spoils of Seattle and you're stuck there
in the middle looking for this very
specific group that has wronged you and
that's the concept of the story and then
it takes you on all sorts of twists and
turns and not about fashion I know even
within the studio we've had a lot of
like philosophical arguments about some
of the events and what happens in the
game and I think and this one might be
more divisive in the first game in a
very kind of exciting way that I think
it raises those interesting
philosophical questions and ask the
players to interpret some of the
material that's there and see where they
stand on those questions
[Music]
please